[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui oui oui on me dit on me dit que
l'invité est arrivé jules a comblé la
tour
[Musique]
toi on va reparler de toile à l'âge est
ce que j'aurais répondu je n'ai pas à
dire je te jure un alors m6 n'a pas
alors c'est l'aptitude savons qu'il est
hors la capitale ça cartonne
ah ouais quand tu prends ma place et si
tu dois vous en donner c'est génial
d'imiter patrick sébastien lord y en a
qui reliait dakar il fumait toute allure
vers trop xiaobo va prendre mais c'est
le but de les amener à il est apparu
mais après je sais pas s'il y avait un
peu de de françois mitterrand mal de
reins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les crocs pour apparaître deux offres
une offre visible et une offre mystère
ces offres sont des défis ou à devoir
relever tous les deux à toi de choisir
en premier si tu veux l'offre vizille où
l'offre mystère du salut au kg au
téléphone un camion shalalala
ouais jonathan je suis désolé mais je
sais pas si tôt quand tu l'as vu mon cul
[Applaudissements]
et si vous deviez comme ça j'avais pas
le bon démission laissez-moi embrasser
crise
avec nous et tout ce qui va se passer
dans quelques instants
quelle élégance toujours aimé regarder
ça et franchement les deux là regardez
regardez kim de la jeunesse que la d2 et
à peu près pareil
est-ce que j'ai gardé les deux ont dit
on dirait il sarkozy fillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez bien la confession d'un
cycle inventer ou à réinventer
confessions intimes est une production
d'une société qui s'appelle qui sud n'a
qu'à dont j'étais propriétaire et c'est
grâce à cette émission pour la première
fois j'ai monté ma boîte de prod donc
j'avais présenté des gels raisons que
tout le monde est très fier d'avoir
inventé saluer
vous êtes très beau d'ailleurs je lui
dit alors en loge c'est vrai dit le
courbet a passé un cap au niveau du
physique vous n'avez pas dit tout à fait
comme ça mais j'ai des petites cloches
et dit tout elle est belle la courbette
ce soir à quoi bon c'est vrai
[Musique]
dit que la vie c'est u2
il
aucune coupe de champagne ou à faire la
gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
alerte donc génériques et sera lui bien
gto au musée c'est de quelques et sur le
quai d orsay
oui oui non eh bien mon tableau préféré
de tous les tableaux originaux
c'est pas lui c'est julien coupat unis
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
lacroix
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
comment mes lunettes s'il te plaît tant
dans le titre du programme un peu
rock'n'roll auquel on a pensé ses
courbes et vous pisse à la raie oui je
rigole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
quelle personne avec qui j'ai travaillé
manquer plus est vraiment je le redis
c'est toi qui a énormément et c'est vrai
que tous les deux julien et moi on se
disait tous alors c'est vrai qu'il y
avait des moments où on va pas se mentir
ou parfois on n'était pas d'accord sur
des choses mais on se disait toujours
tout et c'est vrai qu'on a eu on a eues
j'étais c'est un bonheur de travailler
avec toi je te le dis dans toutes les
années où j'ai travaillé avec toi que ce
soit la folie c'est celui qui me manque
le plus
je te le dis voilà c'est un bonheur
voilà je mets en route est encore longue
et exactement
[Musique]